Північ Чернігівщини, неподалік українсько-білоруського кордону.
Один з механізованих підрозділів відточує бойові навички,
аби бути готовими до всього.
Бойові стрільби: відпрацьовуємо парами,
стрільби із заміною магазинів.
Новини про новий можливий наступ з Білорусі з'являються
дедалі рідше, але тут, на білоруському кордоні,
про загрозу з півночі не забувають. Ось такі навчання зі стрільби,
тактики й медицини тут проводяться регулярно і за будь-якої погоди.
Поки ці бійці боронять північний кордон.
Але будь-якої миті, за потреби, їх можуть відправити
на інші ділянки фронту.
Завжди є над чим працювати. Завжди.
Навіть якщо ти мега досвідчений боєць, вчитися працювати
завжди є над чим. Тому сьогодні хлопці - молодці,
відпрацювали, із заходами безпеки найголовніше,
закріпили на практиці свої навички та знання.
Тобто бойова готовність особового складу на найвищому рівні.
Кордон на замку. Як би там себе не повів противник
- він нас не пройде.
Серед військових чимало молоді. 21-річний Ярослав
пішов служити чотири місяці тому.
Навчання проходив у Латвії, а тут, на стрільбах
у даному місці я перший раз.
Хлопець певен, що ворог не наважиться знову
перетнути північний кордон України.
Не піде, дамо жару. Не боїмося!
Поруч тренуються і більш досвідчені військові.
Андрій на фронті з 2017 року, а з початку повномасштабного
вторгнення був одним з оборонців Чернігова.
Зараз більш менш спокійно. Деякі ділянки обстрілюють росіяни.
Але не можна розслаблятися. Порох треба тримати сухим
і зброю напоготові.
Серйозно військові ставляться й до занять із тактичної медицини.
Ви подивилися - осколок у нього пройшов, черканув.
Значить турнікет йому не треба.
Олександр, який вдає пораненого, знає, що такі навички
можуть врятувати життя.
Я їздив у зону бойових дій, Житомирська область.
І там відпрацьовували ці дії. Коли копали окопи -
прилітало, ми забирали поранених, забирали вбитих, на жаль.
Я особисто забирав поранених. Для свого віку це дуже важко.
Активно тренуються військові й по інший бік кордону.
Як повідомляє український Генштаб, Білорусь привела
окремі з'єднання та частини у вищий ступінь бойової готовності.
Правозахисники кажуть, що в країні триває прихована мобілізація,
призвати пропонують навіть студентів.
Усе це на тлі обіцянок Володимира Путіна вже влітку
розмістити в Білорусі тактичну ядерну зброю.
Треба буде - ми з Путіним вирішимо і введемо сюди,
якщо треба буде, і стратегічне озброєння.
І вони це мають розуміти, поганці, там за кордоном,
які сьогодні намагаються підірвати нас зсередини і ззовні.
Ми ні перед чим не зупинимося, захищаючи свої країни,
свої держави і свої народи.
Протягом останніх місяців Олександр Лукашенко регулярно
зустрічається з російською верхівкою.
Він вимагає від Москви нових гарантій безпеки:
аби Росія захищала територію Білорусі як свою.
Експерти застерігають: можливе посилення російської
військової присутності у цій так званій союзній державі.
Водночас військові РФ і так постійно перебувають у Білорусі.
За даними української прикордонної служби,
їх там близько чотирьох тисяч. Та про формування
ударного угруповання поки не йдеться.
Прикордоння Чернігівщини, яке межує з Білоруссю,
живе більш менш спокійно. З Білорусі не ведуться обстріли,
а від жовтня звідти в Україну не летять навіть
ракети й "Шахеди". Натомість з території Росії,
яка теж межує з Чернігівщиною, по прикордонним селам
постійно працюють міномети й ствольна артилерія.
Звуки вибухів чути навіть у містечку Городня,
що за понад 20 кілометрів до кордону.
Постріли, вибухи чуємо. Мабуть, люди уже звикли до цього.
Перетерпіли, живемо, як раніше.
Це місто одним із перших зустріло колони російської техніки,
які рухалися на Чернігів 24 лютого 2022 року.
Нині, через понад рік після звільнення,
залишки цієї техніки нагадують горднянцям про війну.
Спочатку коли їх вигнали, коли почали люди поступово
приїжджати, якийсь був депресняк, депресії у всіх були,
переймалися, що раптом знову… А поступово все стає
на свої місця. Ми знаємо, що нас захищають.
Ми взагалі-то віримо в наші сили ЗСУ, враховуючи,
що в нас чоловік, зять, брат - усі військовослужбовці,
то сюди вони и не підуть. Але ще питання - я хоч молода,
але новини дивлюся - якщо Путін не дотисне…
Водночас у те, що Білорусь повноцінно вступить
у війну проти України, городнянці не хочуть вірити.
Виходить, вони відкрили коридор для наступу на Україну.
Таке… 50 на 50 ставлення до них.
Білорусь, я думаю… Вони завжди приїжджали до нас в Україну,
в Чернігів, у Городню, всюди. Думаю, білоруси самі цього не допустять.
Військові ж звикли готуватися до гіршого.
Біля кордону зведені кілька ешелонів оборони.
Кілометри ось таких міцно обладнаних траншей і окопів.
Саме такі позиції - траншеї, бійнички - створені для того,
щоб підрозділ міг вести оборону, вести вогонь,
не пускати противника піти далі, до наших домівок.
На всіх можливих проходах, де противник може пройти,
всюди зроблені мінні поля, так само на мостах -
мости також підготовані до підриву - всі.
Тобто ми тут повністю підготовлені.
Впевнені, що противник сюди не пройде.
Військові постійно стежать за тим, що відбувається
по той бік кордону. А у вільний час…
займаються "військовою" творчістю.
Поки на кордоні тихо, готують ось такі великодні "крашанки".
На мою думку, вже навряд чи підуть сюди,
тому що дуже багато їх чекає сюрпризів по-перше, по-друге…
провокації якісь можливі і все. Тому що вони теж зрозуміли,
що ми проводимо аеророзвідку, так само вони проводять
аеророзвідку, вони розуміють що їх тут чекає.
Після війни будете нігті робити. Манікюром займатися…